behind me is the biggest plasma
television ever made it's 1080p it's 150
inches plasma television full high
definition and it's extremely thin for
that I mean just look at it you could
actually go behind it it's taller than
Panasonic representative behind us the
colors are so clear responsive and
detailed that you could actually feel
that you are in some of the pictures of
that what's really cool about this is
that it is not vapor where we will see
this television this great technology in
people's homes within four or five or
six years and maybe you'll start seeing
it in the really rich mansions of
America at first but the fact that this
technology is out there and they're
going to be these incredible displays
it's going to have a complete and total
effect on the rest of technology and
content I'm excited can't wait to can't
wait to heaven in my home
you